Welcome back everyone this is Charlie.
This will be my full Rick and Morty season
5 episode 10 finale video giving you all the
Evil Morty you ever asked for and all the
answers about Rick's back story that you wanted.
There are so many Easter eggs and references.
They also set up a bunch of big things that
they'll payoff in future seasons as well.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes I will
be doing Rick and Morty season 6 videos pretty
soon too.
Careful for spoilers for everything, during
season 5 if you haven't seen the episode yet.
I'll number all these as we go along to stay
organized starting the beginning with the
title of the episode Rickmurai Jack, which
is a reference to Samurai Jack, which is an
adult swim show so the gonna bring the Easter
eggs full circle it's an amazing show.
If you've not watched it yet.
This is also meant to play up the whole parody
of the Rick and two crows anime style episode
spinoff franchise with a whole anime themed
opening scene.
So a lot of the intro scene, the characters.
The way they play things the way they animate
things is a prestige of shows like Samurai
Jack also vampire Hunter D with the way his
costume looks in the cybernetic course there
was little bit and then just scroll mixed
in there I think and then a bit of YuYu Hakusho
so a lot of you probably spotted some more
specific anime references and tropes during
this opening scene during the opening scene
they play this whole part of the episode.
As if we are watching Rick spinoff show Rick
into crows is anime show so that's why everything
is animated differently than the rest of the
regular Rick and Morty episodes the title
Chapter 13 a wing and a prayer is just a reference
to this being the season finale of Rick spinoff show
Because a lot of seasonal anime shows now
only have 12-13 episodes was the rick and
Morty season 5 episode 10 finale.
But it's also the finale of Rick into crows
because the show ends right after this one
ricks crows go back to their last relationship
and Rick goes back to the family, so technically
were kind of watching the series finale of
Rick into crows.
But maybe the make a joke about it or references
during season six.
Like is that his costume in the cybernetic
course is very vampire Hunter D. But the whole
joke with the birds wondering he's going to
surrender is a very Samurai Jack kind of joke
is cybernetic wings also seem like they're
meant to be a callback to phoenix person's wings
I also love the way they interrupt Morty's
confession with the full on anime intro OP
even though this is specifically Samurai Jack
inspired it does seem familiar.
So if you think you know specifically which
anime series.
This opening is meant to reference just right
them blown the comments.
But the whole thing with the burden subtitles
in the letters being all weird different colors
and fonts is just a reference to old school
fan subs.
If you ever watched any kind of anime online
in the early 2000's chances are it was probably
of pirated fan sub on one of those early websites
like Crunchyroll for instance, which I she
started out as a pirate anime website but
then try to go legit.
I'm not sure which anime character crows scare
is meant to reference, but is also just another
crows scene joke like is the scarecrow monster
Rick is the crow hero now everything in this
part of the episode is crows seemed.
I think the poster for Tiger is meant to be
a reference to YuYu Hakusho in the whole thing
with 40-year-old adult Morty was hilarious.
There so weird in specific with these old
person jokes because a lot of the rick and
Morty writing staff is getting closer to this
age.
Like a lot of them around the age of 40 or
little bit older man Morty is like the oldest
looking 40-year-old person that I've ever
seen it is genuinely meant to be old Morty
like he took an aging serum, so it implies
that unless he turns into a fitness or a health
nut this is exactly what mortys got a look
like when he turns 40 he did lie about Jerry
dying from a heart attack and summer marrying
a junkie but you could think of it is being
weirdly prophetic like he's foretelling what
will actually happen to them in some dark
version of the future in some universe when
the bartender cosmic poser even though he's
just taking a shot at him, making fun of them,
he's actually correct, because Morty is only
pretending to be old Morty so conversation
getting impatient with Rick asking when you
finally going to kill the crows big bad is
meant to be a metaphor for the entire show
in the Evil Morty of it all.
Because he has been hounding Dan just in the
path the Evil Morty storyline forever.
Which they kind of did during this episode,
but not completely the funny thing is is that
they raise a whole bunch of new questions
while answering a lot of those old questions
about Evil Morty and what is whole plan was
like wait a minute was going on here with
a yellow portal fluid don't worry, I'll talk
about this to end the space between dimensions
that he travels into before he finds another
universe.
They reveal that ricks crows were just using
as a rebound for their previous relationship,
which was supposed to be the big bad crows
scare and now they're just getting back together
to go on their own adventures together.
It brings Rick back to the family sort of
resetting the formula of the show back to normal
Mostly we all knew the Rick into crows spinoff
was just meant to be a bit so it wasn't gonna
last for forever also part of the reason why
think they aired the last two episodes together
is because the twist like they didn't want
people to freak out and think they were actually
doing a spinoff show called Rick into crows
like none I know it still Rick and Morty were
not doing that Rick into crows thing Rick
then calls out the whole metaphor of how their
adventures together were just a metaphor for
romantic relationships.
But then I love how gross they get with the
way they take this back to like speak for yourself
Like the crows were in a three-way with crows
scare let us show him as proof and Rick's
like hell no.
Just runs away when he comes back to the house
he says's trademark phrase wubba lubba dub
dub when Morty opens the door.
But remember, that means I am in great pain,
which is true in this episode, but it seems
like Rick is always in great pain of some
kind, either emotional or physical just depending
on the episode make a bunch more jokes about
Morty being middle age and how he super codependent now
Don't worry once he gets younger and he has
more of his life ahead of him.
Doing this the only real summer moment during
this episode is her trying to get Morty to
buy her friends Molly and I think that's also
meant to pay off the joke about summer wanting
to do Mali before she dies within the real
episode starts with Rick calling it out.
Like hit the ground running with another citadel
episode.
Like the ricklantis mixup when they enter
the citadel you see the blackboard in the
background here with the drawing and chalk
it actually kind of looks like an upside down
anatomical drawing of vagina with the fallopian
tubes Rick and Morty animates all kinds of
random ball sack since stealth Dicks into
the backgrounds of episodes.
If you look hard enough's of your watching
episode and you feel like there's some phallic
shape in the background you are probably correct.
Morty then has to explain to Rick how Evil
Morty was elected president.
Even though he doesn't call him Evil Morty
just skulls and president Morty Rick starts
making fun of that sort of setting up their
whole arc Morty makes even more old person
jokes being kind of cynical saying on they
turn this place in the Glendale he said she
talking about Glendale, California which is
kind of become dignified is a very specific
joke about the Los Angeles area that he jokes
that he so old that it now hurts for him to
poop the rebuild the Morty storage is a reference
to the build a bear stores were basically
they break all of his bones and rhythm apart.
Like he's a stuffed bear Institute back together.
But when they rip him apart into smaller have
the smaller halves are like DH to the age
he was when he was that size the mother left
with the extra 26-year-old version of him,
they just use it for more millennial jokes
with him being super lame than winds up dying
during a police protest like a this is it
right aid to stop this then as he lay dying
get super happy because Morty tells and oh
yes you were influential you had like seven
or eight blogs the mutant Morty then gives
away the whole secret of the citadel setting
up the Evil Morty reveal than the Rick secret
police shoved escort him to Evil Morty, with
Rick calling it out.
The minute we get a with him being Evil, I'm
out of there.
The joke being that his name is literally
Evil Morty when the mutant Morty talks about
the citadel being a weapon of mass destruction
what he's talking about is it was part of
Evil Morty's plan to destroy the central finite
curve Rick breaks the fourth wall when he
says the citadel runs on Canon in the whole
point was to get back to simple adventures.
He's referencing the structure of the show
canonical episodes where they move the overall
plot for like the whole Evil Morty storyline
over a couple seasons versus the one off adventures
the you really need to watch in any particular
order.
Rick also makes a reference to this again
during their dinner with Evil Morty, when
he says one thing the hates is serialized
episodes.
Dana Justin have talked about this in the
past the reason why they like to do more one
offs is very inside baseball TV stuff.
The reason why they want to do more one off
episodes.
Is because those types of shows tend to sell
better in syndication and when they sell more
in syndication the network Dan and Justin
earn more money, so generally just better
business to make shows that are more one-off
episodes.
Even though nowadays you see most live action
shows go to more of a serialized model when
Morty says things are going right back to
how they were it's another metaphor for the
show going back to normal during season six.
Like during Rick and Morty season six.
It will be more of the one-off episodes is
Evil Morty, who was a big part of their serialized
part of the story.
The be canonical part of the story is now
in a different part of the multiverse outside
the central finite curve and it turns out
he never really cared about killing Rick specifically
he just wanted to get away and needed to take
over the citadel to do that they really play
up the whole bond villain tropes with their
dinner with them trying to one up each other.
Rick and Morty figuring things out pretty
quickly Evil Morty, not trying to hide who
he really is or their shared history since
season one with Evil Rick you notice the pin
the Evil Morty is wearing is shaped like this
is little Rick breaks the fourth wall again
when he says there's the reveal after Evil
Morty says eventually I was going to have
to hunt you down and Evil Morty talks about
Rick liking to keep things episodic Rick never
looks back again.
That's more of a money thing in real life.
But the way they structure the show doing
more one-off episodes and sent serialized episodes
Then they dropped the bombshell that C137
rick is the person who originally created
the citadel itself is Morty learns all this
was watching his memories play out.
He learns the reason why he created the citadel
was to get the other ricks off of his back.
Like he got tired of dealing with them.
So he gave them the ideal for the citadel
in the design and trying create a place where
he could find Morty's and have a fulfilling
life with his family.
Even if it wasn't the original version of
his family.
Because remember they died.
So he designed and help make the original
citadel, but they do explain before this that
the ricks had a loose organization already
they had banded together.
But C137 Rick brought them together in a much
bigger way.
So he was like the original president of the
citadel but couldn't stand them and wanted
nothing to do with this.
We just bailed after they finish building
it Evil Morty makes more season one references
when he says they been scanning his brain,
since that Evil Rick episode in that he had
manipulated Evil Rick who he was controlling
this whole time into creating that device
to scan Rick so that Evil Morty could get
the plans for the citadel itself is there's
explain the central finite curve to our version
of Morty.
So the central finite curve is a way of describing
the smaller subset of universes inside the
larger multiverse were in each universe Rick
is the smartest person the actual physical
structure of the citadel itself.
The technology is meant to help separate the
central finite curve from the rest of the multiverse
So not only is it meant to be an actual place
for them to live together it as she serves
a much more important function.
But for example.
Like we see in the end of the episode when
Evil Morty breaks free into the rest of the multiverse
There are other universes outside the central
finite curve where rick is not the smartest person
Like there could be other universes out there
other curves where Beth is the smartest person
like a counselor best on their own in the
Beth centric central finite curve or there
could be another one more Morty's are supreme,
and so on and so forth.
You get the idea we might see some of those
other universes other parts of the multiverse
in future seasons all the scenes.
They show here when they're depicting Rick's
earlier memories are him creating a very early
prototype of his portal gun in building his
spaceship that him messing with Jerry than
snuffles or snowball depending on what you
want to call him from season one episode three
lawn more dog in the last one is just the
plans for the citadel itself.
The whole thing with the bit of the pop up
Stanley version of Rick is meant to be a reference
to the old school marvel comics where there
would be little blurbs explaining references.
Like in him full Marvel comic book there will
be some big plot point with two characters
referencing some past event in there will
be a little blurb with Stanley saying read
this previous issue to find out what they're
talking about also this Rick is literally
designed to look exactly like Stanley before
he scanned Rick's brain the rest the way the
reason why he says he would've had to kill
every Rick on the citadel to get the plans
are because only a few Rick's were around
when the citadel was originally built so only
a couple of them would have that information.
But the next big bombshell they drop and I
would argue that it's even bigger bombshell
is how C137 rick and all the other ricks manipulate
the multiverse.
Alternate universes, alternate timelines to
create more Morty's so they could have more
psychics it's pretty sinister and Rick does
cop to it.
Like yes, but it's complicated so Evil Morty
flashes back to season one episode nine where
he first appeared in the reveal how the ricks
learned that they could use mortys to mass
their brain waves.
But says that gave them the idea to create
the Morty market at the citadel and create
all these copies of mortys.
So in different universes, alternate timelines
they manipulate events so that every version
of beth will always wind up getting married
to a version of Jerry's of the new mortys
will be born in also at the same time.
Their cloning mortys to boost their numbers
even more this thing with the helmets on the
conveyor belt is them just training all the
clones grafting all of Morty's memories onto
them so that they think that their regular
Morty's like our main version of Morty like
none of these mortys will know that there
clones then they show one being delivered
to a Rick who just recently requested a replacement
Morty.
You may also remember this pays off the joke
from way back in season one where the Citadel
tried to offer Rick a coupon for one free
replacement mortys like none of no not now
the replacement would've been created.
Just like this cloned and then given all of
Morty's memories.
So it would've been a perfect backup copy.
As if no beats have been lost.
They show you the factory floor with a store.
The new ones are where they dumped the old
ones to be used is recycled bio matter in
the creation of more new clone mortys than
Rick makes another inspector gadget reference
is made several of those the season and they
reveal Evil Morty hacked everyone's portal
gun says that would kill all the ricks as
soon as they tried using that to escape and
some of the mortys that portal guns the whole
thing with this monster weapon that Rick creates
is basically meant to be a hedonistic power
loop connected to him.
It absorbs his pain, but very masochistic
leap feels pain is pleasure so that's why
it seems like it's getting awful Rick is getting
attacked for the creature than stores at this
energy that it creates passing it back to
rick and his pain pleasure hedonistic loop
powering him up turning him into super Rick
for a little while is a very on bran kind
of weapon for Rick powering himself up using
hedonistic tendencies, but he jokes that is
just meant to be a metaphor for capitalism
Evil Morty also kind of breaks the fourth
wall when he says the quality of dialogue
stops mattering after Rick yells at him, saying
I was shooting you because I him the Collier
dialogue Evil Morty, making the joke that
the quality the dialogue doesn't matter anymore
because it's the finale and they're paying
off all these Evil Morty storylines that's
why he says doing the thing that I want to
do with the curve thing.
Just using terrible dialogue, because as he
said it doesn't matter because they're finally
paying the storyline off mostly whatever was
getting shredded in all these different portals
are kill when they try to portal way, some
of these are callbacks to the blender dimension
also from season three episode seven.
Some of these are different though.
Like I really like the one with a giant hand
skewering Rick with in all of in a pick like
he's making a giant martini the whole joke
with the news channel anchor saying that he was lying
The whole time because he is being paid by
pharmaceutical companies is the show.
Just taking shots at
most large cable news channels being puppets
of advertisers who pay them tons of money
then they reveal the full scope of Evil Morty's
plan.
So he never wanted to kill Rick at any point
he only wanted to escape the central finite
curve to get to a place where Rick's were
not supreme.
Because every universe in the central finite
curve was chosen because they were universes
where rick was the smartest person.
So when he says he needs the schematics for
the citadel dimensional Drive it's the drive
the powers their ability to maintain the central
finite curve Morty uses the device to see
Rick's entire history.
So a lot of moments year, but a lot of this
backstory I've already explained that we got
a lot of the scenes earlier this season with
a reveal previously that the events of season
three episode one were true the whole time.
Rick just lied about them being a fake memory
this other Rick from the group of ricks that
predated the citadel really to kill his wife
and his daughter Beth in order to get him
to join them.
The language for a while, and depression.
They created a portal gun and went around
the multiverse trying to find him and kill him
But not succeeding.
So go back to season three episode one there's
that joke about the Szechuan sauce being his
one armed man really is one armed man.
If you think about is that Rick who killed
his wife and daughter.
So maybe maybe they'll pay that off in the
future episode.
It seems like a huge deal like that's almost
as big of a teaser as the whole Evil Morty,
alternate multiverse out here storyline you
notice the first version of his spaceship
here he created was super advanced looking
as opposed to the one he uses now this made
out of household items.
The thing is is that his original spaceship
was only designed for one person it wasn't
till he started living with the family again
having psychics that he made the larger one
for multiple people you see that he was trying
to actually have a little bit of fun and enjoying
himself while also searching for his wife's
killer.
Like he looks the pizza box before he says
on his plan to create the portal gun of the
spaceship in then gets the idea to travel
to the pizza themed universe where everything
is pizza which is another callback to the
pizza planet they travel to when they're running
through different dimensions earlier on the
show.
So is revealing that he that she been to this
planet before this train traveling through
the portals in space seems like a version
of the story train.
Even those little bit different.
You see them fill in the rest of his timeline
before he met birdperson how he traded for
items that he needed that slowly grew colder
and eventually as time goes by search look
more like the Rick who we saw during the birdperson
origin story with a longer hair you do see
a couple of his adventures with birdperson
as their timeline catches up with the events
of the battle of blood Ridge with a breakup
in then he continues going back to searching
for that other Rick the killed his wife and
child.
That's where he starts to learn about the
loose organization of ricks that predates
the citadel of ricks he goes around killing
different ones searching for the man to kill his wife
This whole big sci-fi maze seems like a trauma
reference.
Then after failing to find him just gets drunk
back in his house and starts picking off all
the ricks that the organization says after
them.
Proceeding to kill 99% of their groups population
in one fell swoop.
After which the few survivors kind of bowed
to him is a God and he creates the citadel
of ricks to get them off his back taking off
as they finish it also engineering the citadel
to create the central finite curve where he
can find versions of his family in live out
happy life where he then goes back to find
the best who's Rick had abandoned her settling
in with her pretending to be her Rick as we
learned earlier this season in the whole point
here where Morty comes out of the trance and
says dead wife is them basically joking that
the whole reason why Rick is the way he is
what he did all these crazy things is because
of his dead wife.
Like you can literally explain it into words.
So why was it necessary that we have this
whole flashback montage which is one of the
reasons why Dan and Justin say that they been
resisting explaining this stuff for so long,
because ultimately it's not the most interesting
thing about the show.
Like some things are more interesting when
you don't totally understand them.
Which is why Rick then says out loud now everyone
can shut up about it.
Life just now everyone can shut up about it
because Dana Justin saying please stop asking
us about this that Evil Morty tries to frame
things like ricks or the villains here trying
to justify their actions and not take responsibility
for all the terrible things that they do,
especially all of them mistreating their mortys.
So the whole idea here is that Evil Morty
came from a universe where he learned the
truth of his existence.
This, like grand moment about the way they clone
all these mortys in the existence of the central
finite curve and then hatched his plan to
escape and everything is done up to this point
has been to fulfill that plan.
So the whole idea with him taking over the
citadel was that it was just an excuse to
get the technology needed so that he could
escape this part of the multiverse.
I also love how he tells our Morty oh you
been Evil Morty to any time that you hated
your Rick you become an Evil Morty see there
you go, your Evil Morty now is like the show
is saying the Evil Morty is more of a concept
than actual big bad villain.
If it wasn't clear the whole operation Phoenix
reference here is them paying off the joke
from season two episode seven with little
Rick he reveals that he had this program to
jump into different clone bodies to be used
as backups if he ever died.
They also kind of did a version of this during
season four with him hopping into different
universe bodies Evil Morty's hack the system
though.
So they all get rerouted to this device.
But the thing is that they blend their DNA
and use the DNA of these bodies to power up
the giant portal laser and open a tear to
the rest of the larger multiverse Rick then
shows that he's not a total monster by saving
all the mutant mortys and when the saucer
section of the citadel breaks off is a giant
escape pod this is just a big star trek the
Next generation reference when they used to
detach the saucer section of the enterprise
when Evil Morty travels through what looks
like a black hole here.
This is a reference to both 2000 one space
odyssey and interstellar because he uses the
black hole to travel through time, so to speak.
Even though Evil Morty is traveling through
time.
Each of traveling to another part of the multiverse.
They're all these other universes that he
traveling pass these globe the not meant to
be planets their other universes.
So he's in this extra dimensional space between
universes is implied the yellow portal gun
is a special portal gun that allows someone
to travel between universes outside the central finite curve
Whereas the regular green portal fluid will
only take you to different universes inside
the central finite curve in the real thing
here.
They kind of imply through this is that there
grinding up bits of ricks and Morty.
So like their DNA combined is what helps make
the yellow portal fluid.
It feels like they're getting into some Loki
marvel territory with all this multiverse.
Alternate universes stuff the connection here
is the person who wrote the episode.
Jeff Loveness is actually writing Ant-Man
3 quantumania.
The main film of that is going to be the true
Kang the conqueror of the MCU.
So you get into the Kang multiverse war not
till you wonder if they teasing this larger
multiverse outside the central finite curve
if we'll see a version of that play out in
the rick and Morty multiverse at some point
one of the big tropes of the Kang multiverse
war is other versions of Kang going around
destroying entire universes in one of Evil
Morty's major goals here was to destroy the
central finite curve or the sanctity of the
central finite curve that's what's happening
when you see the citadel blow up and you see
all these different yellow globes that represent
the different universes of the central finite
curve start looking like they're blowing up
effectively what Evil Morty has done has opened
up all these versions of rick and Morty to
the larger multiverse is opening up to the
possibility that there are a lot of universes
that will crossover with in the future where
rick is not supreme being is there potentially
a lot of new threats, but they pay off the
earlier reference about them taking things
back to normal when Rick gets Morty's help
to complete their escape.
Like they were appear again help me out help
me save the date here and they watch as the
citadel of ricks is completely destroyed so
RIP citadel.
This time it seems like for good.
Like this is Dan and Justin saying were not
gonna be doing any citadel of ricks stories
on the show anymore.
But then they do another classic Mr. poopy
butt hole post credit scene in the same style
as season two and season three's ending continuing
the theme of him just suffering the consequences
of their previous adventures.
He explains he lost his job at the University
where he was teaching because the heist episode
during season 4 with Rick it eventually destroyed
his marriage to now, he's living like Jerry
was when he had his apartment living away
from the family, his whole speech about being
honest with the ones you love is meant to
be the whole theme of the actual finale episode
about not telling lies to the people you love.
Even if you think you're trying to protect
them from yourself.
This really is super deep here witch's trademark
Rick and Morty.
But as far as we know right now Rick and Morty
season six will premiere sometime next summer
around the same time this season 5 premiered
he did spot any more Easter eggs during the
finale episode that I didn't talk about during
the video just right them blown the comments
my full marvel what if episode 5 video will
post Wednesday just like normal and I just
did a separate Rick and Morty season 5 episode
9 video you can click here to watch that and
click here for my full shang chi post credit
scene ending video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys the next one!